[Music]
who drives
like a bat out of hell a toretto exactly
but i
[Music]
work
is
well that was new this is my legacy
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
[Music]
are you ready to go whatever's on you is
you ready
[Music]
oh
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
[Music]
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
man we messing with magnets now
it's been my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
you acting like we on our way to home
depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
you